joe biden's been in government forever
let me ask you a question on this peter
schweitzer
did the communist chinese regime
make it part of their mission
to invest in the biden family knowing
full well that joe biden was a long time
career politician with lots of influence
i think there's no question mark and
look we spent more than a year
investigating red-handed and one of the
most startling things we uncovered is
the simple fact that the biden family
while he was vice president of the
united states and continuing when he
became president
received some 31 million dollars
from chinese
individuals who are linked to the
highest levels of chinese intelligence
31 million dollars whoa yep yep 31
million dollars uh and these deals uh
which we lay out in the book um were
carried out by a couple of individuals
uh one is a guy named chai fang
hunter biden in the hunter biden emails
refers to him as the super chairman
that's kind of his nickname for him uh
and he says in one email i don't believe
in the lottery anymore but i believe in
the super chairman now who is che feng
he's kind of this sketchy uh chinese
businessman his business partner at the
time that he was striking deals with
hunter biden
his business partner was the vice
minister
at the ministry for state security
he was in charge of among other things
recruiting foreign nationals to spy for
china he was ahead of something called
the number eight bureau
it doesn't get any higher than that
these are the sorts of individuals that
were striking deals with hunter biden um
in this particular case chaefeng
happened to happen to help a 20 million
dollar deal be secured
another individual that helped arrange
that deal
is a guy named mr zhao
mr zhao helped with that 20 million
dollar deal he also sent 5 million
dollars to hunter biden
and he sent that money from a very
interesting business called harvest
global
so you have mr zhao sending five million
dollars who's his business partner mark
his business partner is the daughter
of the former head of the ministry of
state security this is the guy who runs
the entire spy apparatus for china
again it does not get any higher than
that so what this means mark is that in
total the biden family got 31 million
dollars they performed no discernible
legitimate business activities as i can
find for that 31 million dollars and it
all every single deal came from
individuals tied at the highest levels
to the chinese intelligence apparatus so
there's no question in my mind that they
were targeted by the chinese
and for the life of me mark this is
unprecedented i don't know of a time in
american history where the american
first family
has had this kind of a financial bond
with a foreign intelligence service
particularly a foreign intelligence
service that wants to
defeat the united states in global
competition
you know peter schweitzer ironically the
emoluments clause that they used to talk
about what trump
has as its purpose to prevent this sort
of thing
where somebody who becomes president or
other people in the family are basically
paid off
or
invested in they'll use that phrase
by a foreign government they had great
fear about this sort of thing
and i cannot believe that 31 million
dollars as you write pours into the
biden family and joe biden doesn't know
anything about it
he is the the head of the biden clan
that's number one number two they all
live very well
uh number three it is amazing how this
democrat congress doesn't want any of
the tax returns of any of the biden
family members there's been no
investigation of any of the biden family
members he's the current president of
the united states
uh when you consider how they've gone
after donald trump with these uh with
these fake issues
joe biden directly
how has he benefited from the communist
chinese well it's a great question mark
he directly benefited because the other
uh thing that we lay out in the book is
it's very very clear that hunter biden
and joe biden have had intertwined
finances uh for a very long time
what on what do i mean by intertwined
finances well you know there are
communications where hunter biden
complains to other family members that
he's having to send half his money to
pop
which is his father but there's also
specific examples of him paying his
father's bills uh some of them are
rudimentary there's a 320
uh a month phone bill uh for for a back
channel phone that joe biden has when
he's vice president of the united states
hunter biden's paying that but there's
also tens of thousands of dollars of
other bills in terms of renovations on
biden family homes
etc so the bottom line is
money that hunter biden connected
overseas directly benefited
not only hunter biden but joe biden
himself and other family members
including james biden there's a couple
of million dollars of the chinese money
that ends up being
sent to james biden
one other point to make mark which i
think is very important and i think
lays out the fact that this needs
serious investigation
not only by the fbi uh but also by
congress with subpoena power something
very curious happens when hunter biden
is securing these deals there's five
deals we've identified that are linked
to chinese intelligence hunter biden
goes to the secret service and says i no
longer want protection when i travel
overseas uh that is a stunning thing
that needs to be looked into
he doesn't want records i guess where
he's going and who he's talking to yeah
this is all something that just kind of
floats around and the american media
cover it up
they have enormous amount of resources
if they wanted to investigate this they
can raise a lot of questions about it
congress has subpoena power the
department of justice doesn't have to
sit on its hands and yet there it is
sitting on its hands
all the so-called institutions that are
there to protect us from this sort of
thing
seem to be uh devoured and controlled by
the wrong party in this country so
there's joe biden with these various
connections there's his family with
these various connections and all we
keep hearing about is donald trump and
his family
they've been investigated by congress
they've been criminally investigated
which was an outrage they're still under
attack and there's joe biden
31 million dollars came into this family
it's absolutely appalling
when we come back
pelosi
and boehner
and others on capitol hill we'll be
right back hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else